hey everyone bandit here and it's
44 days until breath of the wild 2 will
have been revealed to the general public
for a whopping two whole years
two years let me tell you times have
never been weirder on the one hand we
have people leaking stuff about nintendo
and breath of the wild 2 every other day
with playable zelda this and changeable
hairstyles that and green zone eye hand
revealed gadgets blah blah blah and on
the other hand we're facing the oncoming
inevitable doom and takeover of
humankind due to the robotic invention
of ai wherein the best of us will be
captured and used as slaves for the rest
of our lives
so in the midst of our inevitable
takeover of robot kind i figured who has
the time to wait for news on breath of
the wild too am i right why don't we use
that ai while we still can and have it
tell us the story of breath of the wild
too so without further ado sit back
relax and enjoy some good old ai
storytelling before it tries to kill us
all
oh and real quick you better like this
video if you like this video and
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more content to come
or i'll tell the ai where you live
i'm just kidding i wouldn't do that to
you
because it already knows okay so the
first one that i found is called talk to
transformer i actually found this one
from an article on the verge uh but it
looks like what you do is you basically
just give it a little primer paragraph
and then it's just gonna go ahead and
write a story for you so here we go
let's get elon musk out of here uh use a
custom prompt
okay what am i gonna write link and
zelda go exploring
in a dark deep cave uh they stumble
across the uh long dead corpse of one
ganondorf the ground crumbles and the
duo fall to the
area beneath however link is caught by a
mysterious green hand
oh my goodness it oh my goodness it just
figured out that i wanted to use torches
and seriously that's all that i gave it
oh wow this is exciting what's uh
a little bit scary actually let's read
this in just a second alright ai number
one says link and zelda go exploring in
a dark deep cave they stumble across the
long dead corpse of one ganondorf the
ground crumbles and the duo fall to the
area beneath however link is caught by a
mysterious green hand with the use of a
series of torches the two make their way
to a place of green light at the top of
a mountain link proceeds to enter the
deep hole and meets a mysterious being
who offers him a new life by dropping
him into a larger version of the first
dungeon called the emerald grounds and
then teleports away
he meets link's mother wearing the
mantle of princess zelda and the two of
them go on to the fountain of light
a new dungeon is opened and link is sent
to save princess zelda
this is cool not even gonna lie kind of
iffy about the whole lynx mother
wearing the mantle
of princess zelda type thing going on
there but it's intriguing i almost want
to see more but we're moving on to the
next one all right now we have one
called sassbookai writer
points already am i right looks like we
give it some keywords and then we give
it a prompt kind of like the last one
and then it's going to go ahead and
write in some stuff for us i'm just
gonna go ahead and skip through here
okay so for my prompts i put in zelda
link ganondorf green hand torch and cave
which seems pretty accurate given what
we see in the breath of the wild 2
trailer and for my prompt i actually had
to cut it down a little bit because it
doesn't want me to go over 30 words
pretty darn good if you ask me but let's
see what the ai has to say about it
okay link and zelda are exploring a cave
they stumble across ganondorf dead for
many years as the ground crumbles
beneath them a mysterious green hand
lunges forward to save link the legend
of zelda a link between worlds is an
action adventure game developed by
nintendo ead
did it just google search the legend of
zelda i can't tell if this is the
dumbest or smartest thing that the ai
could have done like has ai evolved to
the point to where it's lazy and it's
just like let me google search it that's
like the greatest characteristic of
being human is the ability to be lazy
maybe they'll be too lazy to take over
maybe they won't divide and conquer all
of us anyway this one was kind of lame
let's go to the next one okay now this
one actually looked legitimately very
interesting uh it had me give it a whole
bunch of different like prompts and you
know keywords and protagonists secondary
character stuff like that um and then
it's apparently going to produce a story
at the end so i'll go over what i put in
it real quick
oh and my pen name clearly mr banned it
all right
it's finally time write me a short story
okay i've glanced at it and it's um i'm
going to read this as seriously as i can
and you better not laugh either the fun
sword a short story by mr bandit
link link had always loved deep cave of
ganon with its grubby grim glowy rocks
it was a place where he felt scared
he was a cool serious water drinker with
blonde neck and blue head
his friends saw him as a knobbly knowing
knight once he had even helped a wooden
big cow animal cross the road
that's the sort of man he was
link walked over to the window and
reflected on his rocky surroundings the
unknown teased like exploring cow
then he saw something in the distance or
rather someone it was the figure of
zelda hyrule zelda was a sad princess
with fit neck and short head
link gulped
he was not prepared for zelda
as link stepped outside and zelda came
closer he could see the weak glint in
her eye
zelda gazed with the affection of 1343
mad big boar
she said in hushed tones
i love you and i want to eat a frog
link looked back even more hungry and
still fingering the fun sword well
excuse me princess he replied
they looked at each other with curious
feelings like too relieved rare rat
delving at a very glad exploration which
had reverse audio piano music playing in
the background and two rad uncles
falling to the beat
link regarded zelda's fit neck and short
head
i feel the same way revealed link with a
delighted grin
zelda looked brave her emotions blushing
like a tricky testy torch
then zelda came inside for a nice drink
of water
the end
oh there's more there's more it even
auto-generates some reviews from the
daily tale i feel like i know link link
in a way it feels as though i've always
known him
ended kibler says about as enjoyable as
being hailed on whilst taking in
washing that has been targeted by
seagulls with the squits hit the spoof
says saying the unknown teased like
exploring cow is just the kind of
literary device that makes this
brilliant and zob gloop says i could do
better i feel like these are all
different ai raiding this ai's story
that was so good
we have to do another one we have to do
another one and this time we're going to
make it serious all right it's going to
be really really serious this time all
right going through this very quickly
[Music]
all right guys here we go
this is the serious story
the dank cave of ganon a short story by
mr bandit
zelda hyrule looked at the pointy cape
in her hands and felt scared she walked
over to the window and reflected on her
scary surroundings she had always hated
dank cave of ganon with its grieving
graceful glowy rocks
it was a place that encouraged her
tendency to feel scared
then she saw something in the distance
or rather someone it was the figure of
link link
link was a tenacious warrior with a
pretty neck and tall hand
zelda gulped she glanced at her own
reflection she was a smart serious
monster drinker with blonde neck and
green hand
her friends saw her as a straight square
scientist once she had even saved a
handsome girl that fell down that was
stuck in a drain
but not even a smart person who had once
saved a handsome girl that fell down
that was stuck in a drain was prepared
for what link had in store that day
the smog teased like walking cow making
zelda fearful as zelda stepped outside
and link came closer she could see the
decaying smile on his face
i am here because i want to not die link
bellowed in a determined tone he slammed
his fist against zelda's chest with the
force of 3875
bore
i freaking love you zelda hyrule
sorry sorry
zelda looked back even more fearful and
still fingering the pointy cape
link
i did not like you at first but now i do
she replied they looked at each other
with afraid feelings like too ratty
ravel snatching rat falling at a very
dangerous adventure which had piano
music playing in the background and two
intelligent uncles running to the beat
zelda regarded link's pretty neck and
tall hand she held out her hand
let's not fight she whispered
gently hmm
pondered link
please begged zelda with puppy dog eyes
link looked hurt his body blushing like
an abundant aggressive altar
ben link came inside for a nice drink of
monster the
end well guys there you have it the
story of breath of the wild 2 told to us
a few different ways by ai let me know
what you guys thought of this in the
comments below let me know if you like
this kind of video and if you want to
see ai come up with different uh
scenarios and maybe if you want me to
read them to you heck like this video so
it gets spread around to like an
animator or something that can actually
animate this
greatness that we just read right here
let's make this big why not and once
again remember to subscribe if you
haven't already for much more zelda
content to come we've got a lot to look
forward to this summer so i'm hoping to
see you all there that's all i've got
for this one so as always i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day this
is massington abandoned signing out
peace
[Music]
you